once you've done that like if your ad
doesn't have that the likelihood that
it's going to convert is much lower
period it's just like these are and
what's what's interesting is that you're
like that sounds so basic alex
i see ads all the time from gym owners
even in our community that don't obey
this and then they're surprised that
they're not getting results
[Music]
hey what's going on everyone happy
sunday hope you guys are rocking and
rolling on your sunday
morning evening afternoon whatever time
zone you are watching or listening to
this
in um i recently have been doing a deep
dive
into funnel world um and ads for both
b2b and bbc i've been kind of like
taking a more frenzy report uh lately
and so i wanted to make this because i
recently had a gym owner send me some of
their
ads um and i was like oh crap these are
definitely not gonna convert and so i
wanted to just give
um basic headline stuff that will always
just make you more money
and so um the formula that i've used for
all of the
fitness ads um that we ran and that i
ran at my gym and that we continue to
run
is a simple formula has three parts to
it all right the first part
is duration all right because virtually
every fitness based
uh promotion that you're gonna run is
gonna be uh
x amount of weeks x amount of days
whatever right so it's like 21 day
42 day 6 week 28 day
30 day one month whatever that is that's
the first piece
of your headline okay second piece of
the headline and this is what i see
people
mess up is the kind of uh the benefit or
the result
okay so it'd be like six-week six-pack
if it was for guys right
28-day bikini uh
six-week booty 42-day
detox uh like [ __ ] i'm trying to think
um
you can i mean if you want to even get a
little bit more creative with it you
could say like
28 day skinny friend right so now you're
like then the copy is going to reel that
in
and talk about how um is it wouldn't it
be nice to always be the skinny friend
right because now you're talking about
status within the context of other
people so you're looking at the prospect
within the eyes or from the perspective
of their friend
right and so you have duration first
okay in the headline
and the second piece of headline is
going to be the benefit all right it
could be
leaning down slim down thin waist um
you know small dress like that's where
like the um a lot of really popular one
was uh
a little black dress right because that
was the result that was the benefit
right and so like like loosen a belt
loop like two notches down on the belt
loop so
try and demonstrate what the result is
going to be with the second piece and
that's where just being creative as a
marketer comes in all right
so duration is simple make sure you have
a duration first because that's where
people wanted to see what kind of
commitment
or implied when they're going to achieve
the result
right so it's like if you have a 28 day
drop to belt lo or drop to belt notches
like cool i get it dropped two belt
notches in 28 days cool but you're not
making a guarantee that's just the title
of the advertisement okay
the third piece to this is a power word
all right
and so a power word could be challenge
it could be blueprint it could be
accelerator it could be intensive it
could be um
of course i'll blank while i'm live um
but it's words like that
that are like program you know what i
mean transformation
all of those are going to be like the
the period at the end of the sentence
and so when you're making your ads this
is the headline that would go in the
banner
all right this is the headline that goes
in the banner once you've done that like
if your ad doesn't have that the
likelihood that it's going to convert is
much lower
period it's just like these are and
what's what's interesting is that you're
like that sounds so basic alex
i see ads all the time from gym owners
even in our community that don't obey
this and then they're surprised that
they're not getting results
like i made a video a couple days ago
about like it it's like the news
like if you look at the way the
headlines look on the news they're still
the same
and they all they do is they just change
the characters and your job is the
reporters to go and grab the story
and capture it right so um
duration 28 day benefit
you know six uh uh duration 28 day
benefit uh six pack or
uh you know skinny waist or smaller jean
size
or whatever right and then blueprint
challenge
transformation whatever it is is the
third word all right
and so that is how you go one two three
and that is your formula for headlines
now once you have that the next piece is
gonna be the creative i'm not going to
get into the creative too much because
i've made other videos about that
but using the legion scrambler for
whatever you want to put in your video
or your image is going to work well
right so that's going to be group
workouts a pitch of you explaining what
it is going to be
any images of people sweating together
in the group together
testimonials work all of that stuff is
creative and you can still use the same
headline
all right the headline doesn't have to
be specific to the creative so it's like
one of the biggest things that i've
learned as a marketer is that you don't
need that those two don't actually need
to be connected
okay now i'll tell you where it does
need to be connected in a second
the next piece that you're going to have
to this is when you actually go to the
copy so i'm only specifically talking
about facebook ads if you're marking on
like
gdn or other things and like those are
banners and you have to have more steps
to it
but if you're just talking about
facebook then what you're looking at
then is the first line of the copy is
going to be calling it who you want
and who you don't want right like
residents that are in this area
right that's what you're like there's
obviously compliance guidelines of
making sure that you can't say you
and you can't say like um you ladies
because you can't identify the prospects
cause facebook doesn't like that right
and so you're gonna do your best to
describe it without calling out
um the person individually who's reading
okay so it's
who we're looking for and if not more
importantly who we are not looking for
okay that can be the first two lines and
then you have your subhead
right which is going to be tied back to
the headline that we said
so it's like if if we said the the 28
day skinny friend
you know transformation right or skinny
friend accelerator whatever program
doesn't matter right
you go there it's like wouldn't it be
nice to be the skinny friend for once we
all have those friends right and that's
the lead-in that's the lead into the ad
it's like we all have those friends
it seems like they can eat whatever they
want and they never gain weight
wouldn't it be nice to know that it's
not their genetics it's actually their
habits
and those habits are programmable and
teachable right now i'm like oh this is
an interesting ad i want to read more
it's like
and over the last x years implied
authority like we've done this with over
a thousand people
in this local area alone and right now
we're opening up our spot in our 28 day
blah blah accelerator
and so if you want to be the skinny
friend then
click over right and say then call to
action and so
like this is a formula like like
hopefully just from the way i'm
describing this you can understand how
this
works so when you're making ads and this
is when a lot of people are making ads
is on sundays
right when you're making the ads start
with the headlines for the actual banner
on the ad itself
all right duration benefit slash results
power word then you have your creative
that's going to plug in
that's really there just to get
attention and make sure that they're
like they pause and stop
all right a fun side note is make sure
that the color makes sense
colors and fonts matter sometimes even
more than the words
so if you're doing a meme banner or a
banner on the ad you want to make sure
that you're not doing black and
yellow or black and red for women right
women are gonna be like that looks
hardcore
right same thing you don't want like
stenciled spray lettering which is like
kind of like hardcore gi joe lettering
for women right it's not gonna work as
well it has a different feel
all right to the same extent if you're
new doing a guys based ad
then doing black and green black and
blue like sort of male based colors is
going to work fine
you sort of make sure that you're
matching those two to the prospect
you're trying to attract
all right and the next thing is like i
said is the font right some fonts work
either way like permanent marker
is a font on google fonts works for guys
or girls right
so you can have white and pink in part
in in permanent marker or font or you
can have black and yellow or black and
red or blue and black or whatever it is
right
obviously you can be in the middle and
just do blue and white or blue green
or blue and white or green and white or
you know with black stencil whatever all
that
that stuff's fine right but make sure
that you're matching that and these
like these are definitely like the
fundamentals like these are the basics
but if you're not doing these and you'd
be surprised
how many people don't do the
fundamentals like the advanced people
just never don't do them and that's all
it is
okay so we're going back to the ad so
we've got our headline
it's in the right font that matches the
prospect and it's in the right colors
cool we have our creative which we know
converts which is gonna be people
working out together
food pictures uh you know
images of like sweaty selfies uh eye
based images where someone's staring at
the camera
selfie pitch videos all of those type of
videos work
right for creative then uh you have your
who you're calling out
to to make sure that you both attract
the right people but ward away the ones
you don't
the not the who it's not for is just as
if not more powerful than who it is for
all right because it shows that you're
selective and you're going to be more
magnetic
and repulsive when you make that right
like if you notice recently a lot of the
gym launch ads that have come out have
been like
no personal trainers like we only want
gym owners who have over 25 clients or
full time have a side lease
and xyz and the reason for that is
because we just did a data analysis on
the clients that make the most money
with us and stay the longest and guess
what
it's [ __ ] gym owners right and so so
we're just making sure that we're 100
clear that that's just what we work with
now you if you want to
look at your own clients and find out
which clients are actually worth the
most to you
and then put it in your copy ward off
the people who aren't good and the
people who do read that are like wow
that's
really me right then they're going to be
way more likely to click and then
the the quality of the click that you
get is going to be much higher all right
and the next thing finally is the
subhead is the lead in
right and that's usually going to be
tied to the
benefit slash result the middle word of
your of your of your headline
right and so if you did the 28 day lose
two notches
whatever transformation right um and
this is where you'd have a little image
of jeans and a belt or something on the
banner right it would make sense
and then when you're with the lead in
it's going to tie it back to that
because like how is this connected
and so you're going to connect that to
like hey
have you ever have you ever have you've
noticed recently that you keep going up
in notches every six months or so
well the good news is it's not permanent
and we know how to fix it right and then
you're like boom then you can go to your
normal copy
okay so um if you're making your ads
make sure to use those headlines make
sure that the banners are set that way
three pieces duration benefit slash
result
and then power word make sure that if
the images slash copy are
uh attention grabbing usually like the
legion scrambler like just use that
um and then when you are doing the copy
on the top
make sure you're attracting and
repulsing the right people and then do
your lead in your sub headline
or what would be your sub headline
because you don't want that actually the
actual banner it's too many words
but you want that subhead because if
they read that then they're going to
want to find out more
they find out more than it's going to
tie into what they just read and it's
going to be relevant
all right once they click from there to
the page
you want it to be congruent all right so
if you're having a 28 day blah blah blah
blah and this is where it's like this is
where it takes work this is where like
good marketers
be mediocre marketers just by not being
lazy and so then they make sure the page
matches the offer and the benefits and
the results that we're talking about on
the ad because people clicked
it's exactly what they want all right
and so that's what we're doing here
so you can have two funnels that are
running for the same campaign just one's
for men and ones for women that's a
basic split
right if you want to get more granular
you can have older women and younger
women
i would imagine that you probably talked
to a 55 year old woman differently talk
to a 25 year old girl
right of course you would right the
messaging changes the way that the page
probably looks different etc
and so that's where you become a better
marketer so anyways i hope that just
gives you just like a quick overview in
terms of gloss if you're making your ass
today because this sunday which is what
a lot of our gym owners do make their
ads
um follow those guidelines you'll get
more clicks you'll get more leads
and if you found this valuable tag
somebody drop a like or comment and if
you're listening on the podcast
please leave review alright keep being
awesome lots of love um i'll catch you
guys soon
you